Los que nos seguís habitualmente lo sabéis
bien.
Aquí, en VisualPolitik, la Rusia de Vladimir
Putin es uno de los temas estrella, uno de
los temas que más solemos tratar.
Hasta ahora, en otros vídeos, ya hemos echado
un vistazo entre otros temas a las implicaciones
de RT, a la estrategia de seguridad y defensa
de Putin o, incluso, a sus resultados económicos.
Sin embargo, nos faltaba un tema clave, y
por el que de una forma u otra muchos de vosotros
nos habéis preguntado.
Teníamos pendiente analizar por qué Putin
es tan popular dentro de Rusia.
Así que, dicho y hecho, veámoslo.
Por cierto, al final del vídeo os tenemos
una pequeña sorpresa y un pequeño reto.
Dicen que después de la tormenta siempre
llega la calma.
Bueno pues en el caso de Rusia esto es literal.
Tras atravesar una durísima crisis en los
últimos años por la caída del precio del
petróleo y las materias primas, por un lado,
y por las sanciones de la comunidad internacional
tras la ocupación de Crimea,
por otro; el gobierno ha sido contundente:
los tiempos difíciles ya han pasado, la economía
rusa, el gran oso ruso está de vuelta.
Pero ¿de verdad?
La prueba de que este gobierno ha capitaneado
la crisis mejor que ningún otro es que su
crecimiento en 2017 será del ¿12?
¿del 9?
¿del 5?
¿del 3?
¿del 2?...
¡Del 1 %!
“Mes tras mes la economía de Rusia crece.
La verdad, mucho, lo que se dice mucho…no parece.
Y eso teniendo en cuenta que Rusia no es un
país precisamente rico y siempre y cuando
nos creamos ciegamente las estadísticas del
gobierno ruso… qué bueno… cada vez más
analistas consideran que….
Como decirlo… tienen mucho de literatura
de ciencia ficción.
Lo cierto es que, aunque es verdad que todo
apunta a que la economía rusa se está estabilizando
los últimos años no han sido precisamente fáciles
para los rusos: según el Instituto ruso para
las Previsiones Sociales, tan sólo en 2016
los ciudadanos rusos sufrieron la mayor pérdida
de poder adquisitivo, de ingresos reales,
desde los turbulentos años 90, ¡qué se
dice pronto!
La crisis y la depreciación sufrida por el
rublo, la moneda de Rusia, ha provocado que
hoy este país, con 145 millones de habitantes,
tenga un PIB similar al de Australia, cuya
población apenas es de 23 millones.
Y lo que aún es peor: hoy por hoy no hay
perspectivas de que la situación vaya a mejorar.
Pues bien, he aquí la gran anomalía rusa,
la prueba de que este país prácticamente
es diferente a cualquier otro.
Ni la crisis, ni los malos resultados económicos
y sociales han dañado la popularidad nacional
de Vladimir Putin.
De hecho, la popularidad del líder ruso se
encuentra hoy prácticamente en récord histórico.
Según sondeos del centro Levada, la aprobación
de Putin entre el pueblo ruso supera el 80%.
Fijaos:
Pero... puede que os estéis preguntando: ¿Cómo
es esto posible?
¿Cómo puede ser que a este hombre la crisis
no le pase factura?
Veamos que está pasando.
Hablar de la economía en Rusia, supone necesariamente hablar de petróleo y materias primas.
Para que os hagáis una idea de la gran dependencia
que Rusia tiene de estos dos recursos, dos datos:
Antes del hundimiento de los precios del crudo,
el petróleo y el gas natural suponían ni
más ni menos que el 70% de las exportaciones
del país y más del 50% de todos los ingresos
del gobierno ruso.
Y fijaos cómo ha evolucionado el precio del
petróleo bajo el mandato de Putin.
Vamos que prácticamente podemos decir que Vladimir Putin tuvo un golpe de suerte descomunal.
Nada más llegar al poder, el precio del petróleo
que se había mantenido estable en torno a
los 20 dólares el barril desde hacía más
de 10 años comenzó a dispararse.
Para que os hagáis una idea: el peso del gobierno en la economía paso el 35% al 70%.
De repente la prosperidad llego a todo el país: en
las ciudades había grúas por todas partes,
los rascacielos crecían como setas y el nivel
de vida de los rusos subía y subía.
Sí, es verdad, Putin dio muestras muy tempranas
de cierto autoritarismo… pero ¿y qué?
El dinero fluía.
Podemos decir que se forjó una especie de
pacto entre la sociedad rusa y su líder:
a cambio de no preguntar por las libertades
civiles o la corrupción, el gobierno garantizaba
la estabilidad y prosperidad de la gente.
Es decir, Putin se convirtió así es una
especie de padre protector, severo sí, pero
capaz de cuidar de sus hijos.
El problema, como siempre, es que estas situaciones,
por decirlo de alguna forma, son muy endebles
y, por supuesto, ningún gobierno, ni siquiera
el de Putin, tiene la capacidad mágica de
garantizar por sí mismo la prosperidad.
Con el precio del petróleo por las nubes,
Putin no hizo reformas ¿para qué? De tal forma que cuando
en el verano del 2014 el precio del crudo
comenzó a venirse abajo la economía rusa
fue detrás.
Pues bien, aquí llegamos, sin duda, al punto
más interesante.
Nada de esto afectó a la popularidad de Putin.
El presidente ruso supo reciclar su estrategia.
Si en un principio fue el garante de la prosperidad,
ahora tocaba reconvertirse en el líder que
recuperaría toda la influencia de la madre
Rusia.
Sí la economía no carburaba tocaba buscar otra fuente de popularidad.
Y Putin la supo encontrar.
Durante 500 años, amigos de VisualPolitik, la ambición de la política exterior rusa estuvo por encima incluso de
sus capacidades.
Desde Ivan el terrible, allá por el siglo
XVI, Rusia extendió su territorio un promedio,
ojo, 80km2 al día hasta convertirse con mucha
diferencia en el país más grande de la tierra
y también en uno de los más poderosos.
Sin embargo, tras la caída de la Unión Soviética,
Rusia entró en una espiral muy negativa de
pérdida de influencia.
Pues bien, esta es la nueva promesa de Putin,
que podríamos resumir así:
Puede que no haya prosperidad o que la situación
económica no sea buena, pero yo, Vladimir
Putin conseguiré que Rusia recupere su peso
en el mundo.
No seréis un pueblo rico, pero nuestra nación
será fuerte.
Pero claro, para que esta estrategia funcione
hacen falta varias cosas:
La primera de ellas es ensalzar el sentimiento
nacionalista: Rusia, Rusia y Rusia.
Por cierto, en la misma línea están los
constantes anuncios de nuevas armas invencibles,
muy poderosas y que garantizan a Rusia
su estatus y supremacía.
Veremos si estas armas funcionan, pero es
más que dudoso que el gobierno ruso pueda
si quiera pagarlas.
La segunda clave necesaria, amigos, pasa por buscar
enemigos que sean capaces de cohesionar al
pueblo ruso en una meta común.
Es decir, me explico, se necesita una amenaza, una agresión, un objetivo que una a los rusos.
Y, para esto Putin necesita una política
exterior agresiva.
La crisis ucraniana, la denuncia a las intenciones
de la OTAN y la ocupación de Crimea, por
ejemplo, hicieron repuntar muchísimo su popularidad.
A ojos del pueblo ruso, Putin está devolviendo
al país a sus tiempos de gloria.
Este segundo punto explica la cargada agenda
que la diplomacia rusa tiene en los últimos años
Puede que no tengan dinero, pero Moscú está en todas partes: Ucrania, Siria,
Norte de África…
Y ojo, para ser sinceros las sanciones que la comunidad internacional le impuso a Rusia tras la ocupación de Crimea,
han tenido el efecto contrario al pretendido:
en general han sido vistas por los rusos como
una humillación y han apuntalando su apoyo
a Putin,
Y por último también hace falta otra cosa:
consolidar la imagen de un líder fuerte,
aguerrido… casi un héroe nacional, un salvador:
Pues bien amigos, esta es la clave de que Vladimir
Putin haya conseguido mantener e incluso incrementar
su popularidad.
Ya no es el garante de la prosperidad, ahora
es el líder que recuperará el poder de la
madre Rusia.
Otra cuestión importante a tener en cuenta
es que el gobierno de Putin sobrevive en buena
medida porque ha sabido crear a su alrededor una órbita de nuevos oligarcas.
Una orbita muy poderosa que se ha hecho de oro extrayendo recursos del Estado ruso.
La concesión de ayudas para capear la crisis,
la entrega a dedo de grandes contratos públicos
o la apuesta de Putin por sustituir importaciones
han beneficiado directamente a estos oligarcas.
Casi todos multimillonarios.
Y, además, Putin se guarda un as bajo la
manga por si las cosas vienen mal dadas: privatizar
o, mejor dicho, entregar las empresas públicas
a estos oligarcas que ponen su poder y su
dinero al servicio de Vladimir Putin.
El presidente ruso ha dejado claro que solo
participaran en las privatizaciones inversores
estratégicos, es decir inversores elegidos
e invitados expresamente por el gobierno ruso.
Y por último, no podía faltar.
La represión política y la represión a
minorías es el juguete favorito de todos los dictadores
y también de quienes lo son en potencia.
Leer, por ejemplo, el último informe de Amnistía Internacional sobre los derechos humanos en Rusia es trágico.
Pues bien,  amigos, ya lo tenemos.
Esta es la receta que explica la gran
popularidad de Putin en Rusia:
Nacionalismo, oligarcas
y censura y represión política.
Vladimir Putin ha prometido al pueblo volver a ser
poderosos a cambio de su lealtad incondicional.
Sin embargo, no parece que Rusia
pueda a medio y largo plazo competir seriamente
con EEUU o China.
Pero... ¿Tú como lo ves? ¿Logrará Putin devolver
a Rusia su poder?
¿Qué prefieres, poder de la nación o bienestar,
prosperidad y libertad  para los ciudadanos?
Nosotros lo tenemos claro, pero esperamos
tu respuesta en los comentarios.
Por cierto, os he dicho al principio que os teníamos
una sorpresa, un reto.
Pues bien, lo prometido es deuda, aquí lo tenéis.
- Enrique... tengo un problema. No se que camisa ponerme hoy.
- Oye, Alberto, ¿has visto lo último del Juan de Mariana?
- ¿Las jornadas de Finanzas?
- No hombre no.
- Ah, bueno, el concurso de camisetas.
- No, el concurso de vídeos.
- ¿Cómo de vídeos?
- Sí, han montado también un concurso de vídeos en YouTube y Vimeo...Y no veas que premios.
- A ver, a ver, ¿en qué consiste todo esto?
- Fonseca, ¿Nos cuentas más detalles?
- Los vídeos tienen que tener entre 1 y 6 minutos de duración.
El formato es completamente libre.
Dicho esto, ¿queréis participar? Pues recordad que la fecha límite es el 7 de mayo de 2017.
Y ¿Cómo podéis presentar vuestros trabajos al jurado?, os preguntareis.
Pues muy sencillo, sólo tenéis que subir vuestros vídeos a alguna plataforma como YouTube o Vimeo.
Y después le enviáis el link a la siguiente dirección de correo electrónico:
Mucha suerte y mucho ánimo a los participantes.
Así que, ya sabes, si te gusta la libertad, o simplemente quieres contarle algo al mundo
¡Qué no te venza el miedo!
No dudes en apuntarte.
Tan sólo necesitas tu ingenio y tu creatividad.
Para más información, en la web del Instituto.